[MUSIC PLAYING]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- I've always seen
puzzles in everything.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Windows can be Braille.
Cards and coins
can be Morse code.
Magazines can be bar code.
Puzzles are all around us.
I see them everywhere, which
is why I started making them.
I have thousands of
ideas for puzzles
that I can make
for you to solve.
And in my other life,
I perform puzzles
that I hope you won't solve.
In fact, at this very moment,
I am making a puzzle for you.
But we'll get back to that.
Puzzles and games have always
been a part of my life.
I've played them, I've studied
them, and I've designed them.
I've been using this workshop to
make something truly wonderful
for you.
It's part puzzle, part illusion.
And it's all going
to happen very soon.
So prepare to look carefully.
Can you crack the code?
Discover the key?
Will you unlock the
mystery, or find out
you've been wrong all along?
There are puzzles in
everything, which is why
I want to share them with you.
Remember I said I was making
a puzzle for you right now?
It's this video
you just watched.
Don't go any further if
you want to solve it.
Go back, and see if you can
find the secret message.
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID KWONG: Maybe we'll--
maybe we'll-- you can think
about it over the next half
an hour.
And maybe we'll play
the reveal at the end,
or you can go online
and figure it out.
It's so nice to be here.
Thank you for having me.
I'm both a magician
and a puzzle maker.
I've basically taken the
world's nerdiest hobbies
and combined them
into one career.
But I think I'm in good
company, which is really nice.
I'm going to speak, today, about
"The New York Times" crossword
puzzle, and puzzle making,
and do a little bit of magic
as well.
Why not?
And did anyone solve
last Sunday's crossword
in "The Times" by chance?
Oh good, that's great.
The 21 by 21 in the
Sunday magazine--
I thought I would talk
a little bit about how
this puzzle came together.
So the crossword rules-- has
anyone ever actually written
a "New York Times"
crossword, or--
have you had one printed?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DAVID KWONG: Oh, that's amazing.
Awesome-- some fellow
colleagues here.
What I love so much
about the crossword
is that you have all
these rules that you have
to obey, all these parameters.
And the biggest
one, of course, is
the size of the grid, 15 by 15.
Or if it's a Sunday,
it's a 21 by 21.
You have to only have
three-letter words or longer.
Two letters-- too easy.
There are no unchecked squares.
That's pretty self-explanatory.
And that also means if you
have some weird crosswordy,
some obscure trivia,
that you cross it
with something that's accessible
that everybody knows, right?
You get into
trouble when there's
two pieces of trivia
that cross each other.
And there's rotational symmetry.
Most of the puzzles,
the black squares
are rotationally symmetric.
So next time you open
up the newspaper,
you'll see that
the black squares--
if you flip it upside
down 180 degrees,
the black squares will
be in the same places.
We sometimes have vertical
symmetry, sometimes horizontal.
All these rules can
be broken, which
is the fun thing about
the crossword puzzle.
And I'm going to show you
some of the famous ways
that people have
broken those rules.
I think that the puzzle really
tests constructors' abilities
to be creative.
Because 365 days a year,
there's a brand-new puzzle
that obeys these parameters.
So how can we come up with a
new trick, a new little story
each time?
And that's what I
think is just so
incredible from the people
that are mailing them
in all the time.
They're always
pushing the envelope,
coming up with something new.
So this was what
I first envisioned
for the Trivial-Pursuit-themed
crossword puzzle, which
is what this was.
It was called "Trivial Matters."
And I wanted to take the colors
from the original Trivial
Pursuit set, the Genus
edition, and have
those relate to the answers.
So the first one I thought that
I definitely had to include
was Dan Brown as the answer
to the literature category.
Yellow, there was a
little more flexibility.
There could be yellow
fever, Yellow Sea.
Pink, I was going
to do something
like "Pretty in Pink," or "The
Pink Panther," Pink Floyd.
Blue was always tough
for a geography clue.
Blue diamonds was this
rare stone that I found.
And I was going to clue it as,
"This precious South African
export--" something like that.
Sports, I was inclined to
go with Syracuse's team
and mascot.
So I originally had Otto the
Orange, that big, rotund mascot
of the Syracuse Orange.
And then science and nature was
many, many options with green--
green peppers, which
I originally had.
This was the first
grid that I submitted.
And I'm only showing you this
because it was completely
rejected by Will Shortz, the
editor of the crossword puzzle,
the guru of all things
puzzles, a great friend of mine
and mentor.
And I did this five years ago.
So he rejected it
five years ago.
And every year or so, I would
take it out again and try
to find a new version of it.
And in the last year,
I came up with--
well, let me tell you
why he rejected it.
He rejected it
because he thought
blue diamonds was not-- nobody
would really know what that is.
And he was right.
No one knows what that is.
Syracuse's mascot,
you can see, I'm
clueing it down
there are the bottom.
Syracuse's mascot,
Otto the Orange,
he thought nobody would
know what that is.
And I think he's wrong still.
I think that you could get--
you could figure that out.
But I revamped things.
And this is what I came up
with for the fourth time
around that I made this puzzle.
Dan Brown, Yellow Sea,
"Pretty in Pink"--
the Blue Hen state is Delaware.
Orange Bowl seemed
to work nicely.
And then evergreen
was my science clue.
And I knew that
I wanted it to be
in a circle in the
shape of the pie--
the wedge carrier
from Trivial Pursuit.
So I knew it was going to look
something like this in a 21
by 21 grid.
I didn't know exactly where
those pieces were going to go.
And it ended up--
I ended up finding
the best distribution.
And it looks like this.
So what you're seeing
here is symmetry
with the theme answers,
right, and the black squares
subsequently, right?
So Orange Bowl and
evergreen are together,
Blue Hen state,
"Pretty in Pink,"
Dan Brown, and Yellow Sea.
You can see that,
right here, you
can't have a one-letter answer.
So I had to fill that in, right?
So you start plotting
these things.
And then you have to
obey all the rules.
So this is the first
shape that it took.
And then from
there, I knew that I
wanted to do "Mellow
Yellow," the Donovan tune,
as coming down like that.
Now "orange man," getting back
to the Syracuse reference,
there was a bunch of
things to play with there.
But I ended up
choosing "orange man"
because of what crosses it.
I'll show you in just a moment.
And "I'm blue" was the--
was a R&B song that worked--
rhythm and blues song
that worked there.
So "Delaware nickname" is
what went across "orange man."
And that refers to-- that's
part of the clue for "Blue Hen
state."
Now there's a little
more flexibility
when I was composing
"Delaware nickname."
It could be "What
Delaware is known as"
or "nickname of Delaware."
But it was that
sort of negotiation
between that cross, that area,
which allowed me to settle
on "Delaware nickname."
And then similarly,
up at the top,
"always has foliage" was a--
for a clue for evergreen--
was also a phrase that I could
mess around with a little bit.
"Never loses leaves," it could
have been, something like that.
But I-- going through
Tom and ending
in E for the "Mellow
Yellow," it seemed
to work really nicely
the way that worked out.
And then you get
into weeks and weeks
of googling things and
looking on Wikipedia, finally,
to get something that
clue Orange Bowl.
I discovered that
the Oklahoma Sooners
have won the most Orange Bowls.
And that went right
through Dan Brown.
That's when the crossword gods
are smiling on you, right?
But that could have
been anything from--
the clue for Orange Bowl--
I was looking at
all these teams.
I could clued as "that
team that won in 1982."
And it could have
been another team.
But that worked
out really nicely.
And similarly,
"Japanese victory"
went through "Yellow Sea."
That could have been "off the
coast of China" or something.
Again, I had a little bit--
I was able to play there.
But then it got really
intense and concentrated
with the last crosses
of the theme answers.
And that was clueing "Pretty
in Pink" with "high school"
through "Oklahoma Sooners"
and "Dan Brown's book
has a secret code."
So when you can cross
your theme answers,
you have a more sophisticated
and elegant puzzle,
in my humble opinion.
But that's something that took
five years to do, basically.
On and off, as I'm
watching Netflix,
I'm working on this thing.
Now you have to put
in the black squares
into the crossword puzzle.
Again, you have to
obey the constraints
of rotational symmetry, right?
Now what I'm going
to show you here is--
I just mocked this up.
This would obey
rotational symmetry,
but there are too many
black squares here.
Because if you can
break the grid up
into so many tiny,
little chunks like this,
it's too easy to make.
This is not hard to fill.
And you can do it by hand,
or you can use a computer.
You can hit a button, and
it'll fill it in for you.
I'll talk about that--
I'm sure you have questions
about that-- in a moment.
But that is why there's
another constraint
on building a crossword puzzle,
which is that you can only
have so many words.
So for a 21 by 21, you're only
allowed to have 140 words.
So this would be way over that.
For a daily 15 by 15,
I think it's 78 words.
And it really is
the perfect balance.
It's made challenging
for us and for you
guys to solve, because
140, it's really hard.
You're always hovering
at about 142, 144.
And you just want
to be done with it.
But you're forced to take
some black squares away.
And it's very hard to
fill in what's left over.
So it's really the
perfect balance.
This is what I ended up being,
the black square distribution
that I ended up.
So what I'm doing
here is I'm carving up
the areas into little--
into areas that I can fill,
the sections and areas
that I can fill.
I'm also putting black
squares in places
that allow me easier fill.
So for example, let's see, I
want I wanted this area here
to start with the
letter V and not
have the V be the second
letter, so I put a black square
right there.
I wanted-- what's another
good example of that?
Yes, I wanted this, also, to
start with a V it was easier
for there.
And notice that I put "pinkie"
as the cross for "pink," right?
"Pinkie's" the cross for pink.
That's because I
didn't want it to be
related to the color pink.
It could have been "pinker,"
or "pinked," or "pinkly" maybe.
But the pinkie is so
far-removed from the color.
Now I wasn't quite able to
do that for all of them.
But "I'm blue" worked well,
because it's an emotion.
"Tom Green," "Dan Brown,"
you're getting last names.
So it makes it more fun,
rather than just have--
what would be a bad example?
Orange-- orange
ball or something--
I don't know-- for basketball.
So that was another
constraint I wanted.
This was a very tough area
here-- blank, I, blank, E--
blank, I, blank,
blank, W. I think
that ended up being "sinew."
But that gave me
a lot of trouble.
And this area here was the
most difficult area of all.
Here's what the final fill
ended up looking like.
And I included
"genus" down here--
I'm sorry, I have
preference to this side.
I've been unfair to
this side over here--
"genus" down here,
to reference, just
because there have been a lot
of Trivial Pursuit versions.
And I wanted to be
able to say, these
are the colors from this one.
And this was the most
difficult version up here--
I mean, area up here.
For those of you
that solved it, I
don't know if you had
trouble with that area.
But that was the most
difficult version.
Here is what it was when
I first submitted it,
this revised version.
And the editors-- and
there's a dialogue
between Will Shortz, and his
team, and the constructors.
They felt that this
area was too hard.
This is what I originally had.
I cut off the Y here.
But this was Denmark Vesey, the
leader of a slave rebellion,
an American vet.
And this is very
"crosswordese" here, E-V-A-H,
which is from a Cole Porter
tune, "Have You Evah"--
"Have You Evah,"
something like that.
And test solvers were
not figuring it out.
And they thought it
was too difficult.
I had "Mister Blue," which
is another song, to go there.
So they suggested that
I change it to this.
They actually made this edit.
And it became-- this is "vines."
I cut off the letter S.
But still had "evah" in there.
There wasn't really
any way around that.
But they thought that "yecch"
was legitimate and gettable.
It's whether or not
it's gettable, right?
And through the crosses--
"Taipei" crosses that.
"Civil" crosses that.
You make those accessible so
people can get that answer.
That whole area, we tried
to clue as easy as possible.
And the answers which appeared
just in the magazine on Sunday
looked like this, which
was really lovely.
So that is the
completed Sunday puzzle
that I made, five
years in the making.
So standard tricks for
the crossword puzzle--
this would be like the tricks
in a letter change puzzle,
as we call them.
So you could have a title
of a puzzle, or a theme--
a revealer of the puzzle
might be, like, "take five."
I've seen this before a couple
times in "The New York Times."
Taking the letter V, the
Roman numeral V, removed--
take five.
You could have-- this
was one I enjoyed
solving many years ago-- "crop
circles" was the revealer.
And you were to take
out the letter O.
Or you could add letters.
Like, if your
revealer was "artoo,"
you would add the
letter R. So that's
kind of a standard trick.
Here's one that I made, which
was a letter change puzzle.
It was-- here the
clues for the themers--
"what a person in an
emergency might have to make."
And then the revealer was this--
"World War I novel hinted
at by the above," which
is "A Farewell to
Arms," which is
a nice-- we love it
when we find things
that are 15 letters
long, or 21 letters long.
And this changed things
like "death warmed over."
You say farewell to the A-R-M,
and you get "death wed over."
You get these punny,
silly phrases.
So this is a standard word--
a letter substitution puzzle.
So then I took it
one step further.
Here's one of my
favorite puzzles.
I co-authored this with
my friend Kevan Choset.
And in 2007, which
seems like eons ago,
we did a puzzle in the Sunday
"Times" called Magic Words.
And once again, the crossword
gods were shining down on us.
Because a perfect 21 across
is-- does anyone know?
Close, yeah, it's
another utterance.
It's "now you see
it, now you don't."
So "now you see it,
now you don't" gave me
not just taking letters away
or adding them, but doing both.
So adding-- now you see it--
I-T to "Bing Crosby,"
you get the silly phrase,
"biting Crosby."
if you're taking "it"
away from "Great Britain,"
you get "great brain."
And those are the long ones
that run across the grid
here, here, here, here.
So "now you see it, now
you don't" was, I think,
one of the first puzzles to do
both taking away and adding.
Here's a puzzle I did not make.
But I love it so much,
because I think it truly
exemplifies how crossword
puzzlers are often
messing with the conventions
of the crossword.
That's my favorite
thing, is we--
as a magician, I suppose--
is we take things that you
know so well, that you're
familiar with, and
then we subvert
it, which is why we use
a pack of playing cards.
Because you all know what--
you hold those in your
hands all the time.
You know what that's about.
And then we do crazy
things with them.
Start of the quote, all the
way through end of the quote,
was revealed as--
the start of the quote
was the letter Q, which
is a British waiting line.
The next part of the quote
is U, second person singular,
Oprah Winfrey's magazine,
drink with jam and bread.
And the end of the quote,
E, is worldwide web prefix.
So I really loved that puzzle.
The most famous
crossword, I think,
that's ever been in "The New
York Times"-- and Will Shortz
will second this--
was from 1996, the election.
And many of you are probably
familiar with this story.
Jeremiah Ferrell
made this crossword.
I don't think it'll
ever be rivaled.
It's the best one ever.
"Forecast," the answer
was "prognostication."
"Title," for 39 across,
which is right here,
was "Mr. President."
And this was published on
Tuesday, on election day.
And people were calling
up "The New York Times,"
furious that even though Bill
Clinton was leading the polls,
that they would
call the election
in the crossword puzzle.
But this is what we call
a Schrodinger puzzle,
meaning the cat is alive
or the cat is dead,
meaning two things work.
So "Clinton" and "Bob Dole"
both worked in this 39 across.
"Clinton elected"-- so
"black Halloween animal"
was either "cat" or "bat."
This is a humor--
great, humorous, clever
one-- "provider of
support, for short"
was either "IRA,"
"Roth IRA," or "bra."
"Trumpet" was, perfectly,
"boast" or "blast" for 35 down.
That is the greatest
puzzle, I think,
"The Times" has ever seen.
So another Sunday puzzle I had
with my pal Kevan Choset, once
again, was "Abridged Edition."
And this one was for all of
you fans of "Mad" magazine.
And that was sort of given away.
If you look closely, you
can see these dotted lines
that are running down
vertically in the puzzle.
And this was the inside
back cover of "Mad" magazine
for over 50 years,
Al Jaffee's fold-in.
Are you familiar with
that piece of artwork?
He's still doing it.
He's in his 90s.
It's incredible.
And this puzzle folded the
right side over to the left,
yielding a new--
new answers.
And where the dotted
lines were, you actually--
if you look closely,
the "B" and "T bones"
would line up with
the "A" and "C clamp,"
and the "B" in "Eberts,"
and the "A" in "straight."
And the instructions
down, vertically,
were "fold pages so "A"
and "B" are lined up
in the top and bottom rows.
I also was able to sneak in
"Mad magazine" into the middle.
And that's what you get
on the right-hand side
when you fold it over
in the gray bands that
run across the grid.
All of these, things, by the
way, are things that fold,
that were revealed--
"lawn chair," "oragami."
"Poker hand" came from
"poke at" and "overhand."
You can see it gave
you "poker hand."
"Origin" and "a
French friend," "ami,"
gives you "origami"--
so all things that fold.
Now this is the first
puzzle I ever had
in "The New York Times," which
was published on April Fool's
Day, which is like the nerdy
trophy for crossword puzzle
constructors.
Again, I did it with
my friend Kevan.
He thought it was so
devious that it not only had
to be April Fool's
Day, but also had
to be a Saturday, which is sort
of the confluence of all things
diabolical.
"What some letters in this
puzzle seemingly have?"
The answer was "no place to
go," "overfloweth," and then
"outside the box"-- how you
must think to solve this puzzle.
And you had to put
"think" inside the margins
of the newspaper for that
April Fool's Day puzzle.
So that's many, many moons
ago, but I'm still proud of it.
And I'll finish
with a last puzzle.
And this is my favorite puzzle
that I ever had in "The Times."
And this was published
on a Halloween,
which is the other time where
you get to be really tricky.
"Things worth looking into"--
"things worth looking into"
was-- in the vertical,
coming down, was "mirrors"--
"mirrors."
And then I messed around
with Universal Studios' roles
in four sections, right?
So you could take a look
and see that "mirrors" were
the things worth looking into.
In the upper left-hand
corner, you had--
"Wolfman" was the answer to
that Universal Studios role.
But then it was clued as--
8 "acloss" was clued as--
"Wolfman, in 23 down"
gives you "namflow,"
is "Wolfman" backwards, right?
Next, you have "monster,"
Frankenstein's monster,
reflected in the
mirror, is "retsnom."
You had it with "phantom."
But then, in the bottom, you had
"Dracula with no reflection"--
[LAUGHTER]
--"with no reflection."
So you have to imagine what
the blank grid looked like.
The blank grid-- people were
seeing 44 down as eight letters
long--
or seven-- is that
seven letters long--
seven letters long, when
it was, in fact, only six.
So it was clued as
"Pacific Northwest city."
I was trying to bait people
into writing in "Seattle."
56 down, "cap," was clued as
"half of graduation attire,"
which was kind of--
yeah.
50 down was--
I was hoping they'd
get the S first.
And it was clued as, I think,
"winter precipitation."
I was hoping to succor
people into putting "sleet."
But that's my favorite puzzle.
And I think it kind of
messes with the conventions
of the puzzle so much,
which is what I like.
So now, that's just
half of my career.
Oh, the aha moment-- let me
speak a little bit about that
before I do a little magic.
The aha moment is this moment
when you, as the solver,
unlock the puzzle, and
you crack it, right?
And what happens in that moment
is a simultaneous thing, which
is you feel smart for
having cracked the puzzle,
and at the same time, you also
respect the puzzle creator
for having come up with
something clever to begin with.
So that's the real sweet spot.
But this mantra that I
take from Will Shortz
and I try to apply in
everything that I do
is that a good puzzle makes
the solver feel smart.
And you could come up
with a uncrackable puzzle
that requires all
sorts of cipher keys.
And finally, people get it.
And they're like, ugh, that
was not-- that wasn't fun.
That wasn't worth it.
A good puzzle makes all
of you guys feel smart.
And that's what I try to do
in my show, "The Enigmatist,"
is involve everybody,
and getting people
to stand up if they
know the answer.
And we're going to do a little
bit of that in just a moment.
But I thought I would
have a little fun
with a pack of playing cards.
You want to see some magic?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DAVID KWONG: Yeah?
OK, good.
Me too.
If you said no,
I'd be in trouble.
I'm going to make it a
little more difficult
and have a number
of cards selected.
So let's try it.
Let's just do it like this.
Can I just have you say
stop for me, please?
OK, will you remember that card?
And people behind you
can remember it as well.
OK, great.
Hi.
Do you mind playing?
Do you mind saying
stop for me, please?
AUDIENCE: Stop.
DAVID KWONG: OK,
remember that card.
You guys remember
that card, yes?
Let's see, I'll get the
sides in just a moment here.
Can you just say
stop for me, please?
OK, a little further
down, like that--
OK, good.
Hi.
Do you want to say stop for me?
AUDIENCE: Stop.
DAVID KWONG: OK, very good.
Excellent.
Did you guys see that?
Hi.
Do you mind just staying
stop for me, please?
OK, right there-- you
guys remember that card.
OK, excellent.
So let's see.
And let's try this.
Do you mind just saying
your favorite card for me?
Do you have a favorite card?
I'll use one more.
AUDIENCE: Seven of diamonds.
DAVID KWONG: Seven
of diamonds, OK--
let's try this.
I'm going to see
if I can get each
and every one of these cards.
I'm going to do this
up on the camera
here so you all can see
I'm an honest magician.
[LAUGHTER]
OK, let's try this.
Here we go.
OK, so this is how
this is going to work.
I'm going to ask you
what card you chose.
If you tell me what
you chose, I'll
try to find it in
the deck of cards.
So I'll try to do this in order.
What card did you-- what
card are you thinking of?
What did you see?
AUDIENCE: Four of diamonds.
DAVID KWONG: Four of diamonds--
OK.
So this is called a swivel cut.
This is called a swivel
cut, just like this.
Should be the four of diamonds.
That's number one.
Let's see here.
Let's see who else--
what card did you have?
The nine of spades, OK.
So this is a table
cut, just like that.
So that would just be
the nine of spades.
Thank you.
Who else had one?
I've lost track.
Are you the next person?
What did you have?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DAVID KWONG: You had
the two of clubs, OK--
two of clubs.
This is me showing off.
That's the two the clubs.
OK.
And what else do we have here?
AUDIENCE: Three of hearts.
DAVID KWONG: Three of
hearts-- three of hearts.
If I-- I'll do this
up here like this.
If I reach out like
this, watch what happens.
I get one card right out
of the-- oh, three of--
I was so close.
Three of spades--
It was three of
hearts though, right?
Actually, I'll just--
AUDIENCE: OK.
DAVID KWONG: Yeah?
I'll just change that
there-- three of hearts.
Oh, now he's getting good, OK.
OK, what else-- who--
what did you have?
AUDIENCE: Six of clubs.
DAVID KWONG: The six of clubs--
OK.
Let's try it like this.
If I take the Jack of diamonds,
watch what happens here.
Right here on the table,
the Jack of diamond
should just change, like
that, to the six of clubs.
OK.
And what was your card?
AUDIENCE: Seven of diamonds.
DAVID KWONG: Seven of diamonds.
All right, for the
seven of diamonds,
you know what, I'll
do this center-stage.
The seven of diamonds--
I will attempt to cut
the cards with one hand,
get one card to fly through the
air about 10 and a half times.
And I'll catch it
here in my right hand.
So here we go.
For the-- seven of
diamonds is your card?
OK, check this out.
It's the top.
It pivots to the bottom.
That's a one-handed swivel cut.
And one card, like this, should
be, just like that, the seven
of diamonds.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
OK, so how about we
play some puzzles?
Let's do some puzzles.
I brought some puzzles.
I made some puzzles
just for you guys.
If you know the answer,
just stand on up.
And I'll call on you.
And we'll have a
little bit of fun.
So here's the first puzzle.
If you know the answer,
just stand on up.
All right, what is your name?
AUDIENCE: Patrick.
DAVID KWONG: Patrick-- what
are you seeing here, Patrick?
AUDIENCE: Greek letters.
DAVID KWONG: Greek
letters is correct.
Where are the Greek
letters, Patrick?
AUDIENCE: In
between [INAUDIBLE]..
DAVID KWONG: They're in between
all the words, that's right.
So the answer to puzzle
number one is Greek letters.
You can see omega
there in the first one.
Greek letters-- Patriot
Act has iota in it.
Final phase has alpha.
Bar hopping gives us rho.
And we have phi, or
"fee" in steep hill.
Nice job, Patrick.
All right, next one--
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah.
Little bit of misdirection
in these, right?
Next one-- stand up if
you know the answer.
Who's missing?
Anyone know what world
we're playing in?
Yeah?
You know world we're in.
OK.
There's an added
constraint on top of that.
You got it?
You don't got it?
Well, what's your name?
AUDIENCE: Eric.
DAVID KWONG: Eric, what
world are we playing in?
AUDIENCE: I think they're
names of presidents.
DAVID KWONG: Yep,
pretty much all of them.
But there's another constraint.
Where did these mostly
presidents appear?
Yes, which one's missing?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] money?
DAVID KWONG: Yeah, it is.
AUDIENCE: I'm not sure
if it's [INAUDIBLE]..
DAVID KWONG: It's the $2 bill.
We got Jackson right here.
These are in order.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah, so--
DAVID KWONG: So
who's on the $2 bill?
AUDIENCE: Jefferson.
DAVID KWONG: Jefferson-- I
know I picked the obscure one,
but well done, guys.
Jefferson-- OK, good job.
All right, next one--
a little bit of movie trivia.
Feel free to tell me
which one is missing.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DAVID KWONG: That's correct.
Does anyone know
which one's missing?
Well, what's your name?
AUDIENCE: Schre.
Schre.
DAVID KWONG: Schre?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DAVID KWONG: What world
are we playing in?
AUDIENCE: Chinese.
DAVID KWONG: The Chinese
zodiac, that's right.
And which one is missing?
Anyone know?
No, we have goat somewhere.
Because goat and
sheep, I think, are--
it's not-- a tiger-- yes, tiger.
Not easy to find a
movie with a tiger.
I had that Colin Farrell
movie at one point.
What's that called?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DAVID KWONG: Yeah,
you can't use that,
because the dragon gets real
confusing when you do that.
Yeah, that's a fun puzzle.
Here's another one
in a similar vein.
Can anyone tell me what
the answer is here?
So who do we have in the
upper-left hand corner?
Yes, Beethoven.
And?
Uh-huh, and?
Uh-huh.
And then who is in
the lower right?
Yes.
What's her real name?
Stephanie Clifford.
OK, that's your hint now.
Yes, what's your name?
AUDIENCE: Mike.
They're all dogs.
DAVID KWONG: Mike, yes,
they're all dogs, movie dogs,
Beethoven, Marley,
Bolt, and Clifford.
All right.
Oh yeah, Stephanie Clifford,
thank you for existing.
What do these five
have in common?
Yes, that's right.
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Eric.
DAVID KWONG: Eric,
you got that so quick.
They all are exclamat--
they all have
exclamation marks in their
titles-- have an exclamation.
All right, and then last one--
last one.
Which one is represented
by this question mark?
These are all albums--
songs from albums.
Yeah.
Oh, you're standing.
Hi, I missed you, sorry.
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Chris.
DAVID KWONG: Chris, what
do you think that is?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DAVID KWONG: Well, what
world are we playing in?
AUDIENCE: Monopoly.
DAVID KWONG: Yes, it's
the Monopoly board.
Does anyone know what is to
the right of chance there?
AUDIENCE: Oriental.
DAVID KWONG: Oriental is
correct, Oriental Avenue.
Amazing.
All right, so I
want to know if--
there's something
in puzzling called
the meta puzzle, the answer
that synthesizes everything
together.
I want to see if you
guys can figure out
what is the meta answer here.
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Masten.
DAVID KWONG: Masten?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DAVID KWONG: Masten, go to town.
What are you doing?
AUDIENCE: The fourth
letter [INAUDIBLE]..
DAVID KWONG: And what
does that spell, Masten?
AUDIENCE: Enigma.
DAVID KWONG: Enigma--
OK, thank you.
Let's give her a
round of applause.
Yes.
Wow.
I don't even know that happened.
That's crazy.
In a moment, I'm going
to answer some questions,
have a little
conversation with Tom.
But I just wanted to say that
I'm doing this show called
"The Enigmatist" at the
High Line Hotel, which
is right around the corner.
And it's a lot of this.
First of all, you have to
solve an escape room to get in.
It's not that hard.
Everybody gets into the show.
There are ample hints.
We get a hundred people through
that room for each show.
So it's not like you're
trapped in there forever.
And there's a lot of
this, stand up if you know
the answer, a lot of illusions.
But my favorite
thing about the show
is that it's also a story from
over 100 years ago from 1915.
And I'm just going to quickly
show you the characters.
George Fabian was this
super-rich Willy-Wonka-type
character who bought a 350--
acre estate in Geneva, Illinois.
And he bought it
in the early 1900s.
And he called it Riverbank.
And it was-- this
is Riverbank Labs.
It is the first ever
privately funded laboratory
in the United States.
And Riverbank Labs still exists
in Geneva, Illinois, actually.
He had a Japanese garden.
He had alligators roaming the
property, a giant spiderweb
that guests would climb on.
He had this windmill.
And he had bears and zebras.
And it was totally insane.
But he brought together some
of the world's greatest minds,
scholars, and scientists.
And two of the people
that he brought together
were Elizabeth and
William Friedman.
And these two would end up being
America's first code breakers.
These are the parents of
American cryptography.
And it's all about their
journey from his crazy estate
to Washington, DC
and all the code
breaking they did
in the world wars.
So if you like puzzles, and
code breaking, cryptography,
and magic, please join
me at "The Enigmatist"
at the High Line Hotel.
And I hope you enjoyed that.
And I think we're going to have
a little conversation now as
well.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
TOM SMITH: Have a seat.
DAVID KWONG: OK.
TOM SMITH: And we'll
have Q&A in just a sec.
But maybe now we can get the
rest of the video that we--
DAVID KWONG: Oh, yeah.
TOM SMITH: --paused at
the beginning of the show.
DAVID KWONG: Sure.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Now that the answer to
the puzzle is Riverbank,
what do you do with it?
I've hidden a second secret
message in this video,
but I'm not going to tell
you where to find it.
And for those who do find
it, there's a fun surprise.
Either way, looking forward
to seeing you at my show,
"The Enigmatist."
Happy solving.
[END PLAYBACK]
DAVID KWONG: There is a
second puzzle hidden in there.
And it leads to a web page with
many more puzzles to solve.
And you can get on the
board of expert solvers
that we place on the website.
I'm very easy to
find on social media
if you want any hints
on where to look.
But puzzles lead to more
puzzles, lead to more puzzles.
It's a crazy puzzle
party, people.
TOM SMITH: And my wife
and I have seen the show.
And we walked out with
the best kind of headache.
It's really, really a fun show.
DAVID KWONG: What
makes me different
from all other magicians--
or 99% of them--
is I don't pretend to have
superpowers in any way, right?
I say, at the top of my
show, that it's all a puzzle.
And if you figure it out, if
you can decode it, good for you.
So feel free to discuss it
and try to figure things out.
And I love that you're
already thinking about things.
AUDIENCE: Do you
have any sympathy
at all for people who
just go insane not knowing
how you do these things?
Because I can't see
a show of magic.
I just-- it bothers me a lot.
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID KWONG: I
don't have sympath--
no, I love that.
[LAUGHTER]
I think-- what bothers me is
when people pretend, beyond
what occurs in the theater,
that it's real, you know?
So mind readers
and mentalists kind
of border a little bit,
for me, on what's not fair.
And then when you get to
people that really cause
harm are the fortune tellers
and these spiritualists who
tell you, you don't have
to go to the hospital.
I'm curing you of your cancer.
I think that's not OK.
But within the context of a
show, of a theatrical show,
if I'm going to
leave you puzzled,
I'm totally OK with that, yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'm always amazed
at some of these puzzles
that you pull off.
Going back to the "New
York Times" crossword,
a lot of people are
doing them online now.
And I'm wondering how
that changes your approach
to making puzzles.
Is it easier?
Is it more difficult?
Do you have to do
fewer things if people
don't like filling
in a rebus puzzle
online-- things like that.
DAVID KWONG: That's
a great question,
because it doesn't
change my approach.
I suppose I'm writing it for
the good old-fashioned paper
puzzle.
There was some
criticism that came out
about my puzzle
last Sunday, which
is that the whole thing
was in order to reveal--
if you solved it online,
the colors popped up.
And there was a little
music, and some animation,
and a little dance--
that that was the
purpose of the puzzle.
And it wasn't, you know?
You can do that on paper.
You can write the word
"blue" in with your pen.
If you happen to have colored
markers, that's more fun.
But no, I think
solving has changed.
People solve crazy fast
now on the computer.
A friend of mine--
I've never seen someone
solve this fast.
The Saturday puzzle,
which is the hardest,
he solved in, like, two minutes
and eight seconds or something.
And they're only
doing the acrosses.
And it's just unbelievable.
And I think the mini puzzle
is a great thing, also.
It's kind of a gateway drug
to the crossword puzzle.
So I'm sure a lot of
you guys do the mini.
I think it's all good that
it's going digital, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
DAVID KWONG: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thank
you for coming.
So I'm attending the American
Crossword Puzzle Tournament--
DAVID KWONG: Nice.
AUDIENCE: --next month
for the very first time,
and I'm super nervous.
So I'm curious if
you have any advice
or experience with
competitive puzzle solving.
DAVID KWONG: I've been to
the ACPT many, many times.
I've never competed.
I hang out and have fun.
And it's the warmest,
friendliest, nerdiest people
in crossword costumes.
And there are fun
games and meals.
And I've never competed,
because I'm actually
a better crossword
designer-- that's
my way of thinking--
than a solver.
And I would get totally
trounced by these people
that can solve so fast.
But there are
different brackets.
And everybody finishes.
And even if a Sunday
puzzle comes out
and it takes you an hour
to do it, no one cares.
So you're going to
have the best time.
It's in Stamford?
Or is it--
AUDIENCE: Stamford, I think.
DAVID KWONG: Yeah,
yeah, that's great.
I wish I could go.
That's awesome.
Have fun.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
This was amazing.
I do crosswords, and
have been doing them
for a couple of years now.
And one of the things I'm
really impressed with by people
who do them a lot is
meta-crossword knowledge,
like knowing these tricks,
remembering this puzzle
from 2017, and
quickly accessing it.
Did that come naturally to you,
or did you develop that skill
at some point in the past,
basically knowing the tricks
people use and remembering that
there's this crossword three
years ago that did this
that's a useful thing
to use as an example?
DAVID KWONG: Yeah, I'm
thinking about it all the time.
And I've done every puzzle,
every day, for over a decade.
So I do remember
most of the-- when
I try to come up
with a new trick,
I do my research to see if
anyone else has done anything
like that.
And I try to make it fresh,
and new, and different.
Also, I think your
question applies a lot
to solving, which is that
it is a computational skill.
And like Scrabble also, it's
actually not really a word
exercise.
It's and the people that win
the ACPT, the crossword puzzle
tournament, are more
often than not--
because it's based on speed--
math and music people.
And it's people's
abilities to draw
from a database of
knowledge and knowing,
when they see the word
"hero," that it's not
talking about Superman, but
probably a sandwich, you know?
And it's just, like,
pulling really fast.
AUDIENCE: OK, cool.
So just lots of
practice, it comes.
DAVID KWONG: Yeah,
and when you love it--
AUDIENCE: Good answer.
DAVID KWONG: When you love
something, you just know it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, sounds good.
Thank you.
DAVID KWONG: Yeah, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I really like the
cryptic crosswords--
DAVID KWONG: Yes.
AUDIENCE: --that are more
popular in UK and Australia.
DAVID KWONG: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And I've been really
disappointed that there's not
so many cryptics--
DAVID KWONG: There's just--
AUDIENCE: --here.
DAVID KWONG: --one a month, I
think, in "The New York Times."
AUDIENCE: Oh, really?
Oh, OK.
DAVID KWONG: Yep.
Yep.
You can get it--
they must not print it.
Will Shortz is going to be
mad at me if it isn't printed.
I apologize.
But it's certainly online.
And I solve it
online once a month.
AUDIENCE: Oh, beautiful.
AUDIENCE: You can't do it in the
app, but you can do it online.
AUDIENCE: Sundays.
DAVID KWONG: Is it in
the Sunday magazine?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DAVID KWONG: Yep.
It's sometimes in
the Sundays, great.
AUDIENCE: Oh, cool, once
a month-- all right--
DAVID KWONG: "The Atlantic"--
AUDIENCE: --thank
you for helping.
DAVID KWONG: --does
one, I think,
that's quite well-renowned--
"The Atlantic."
But the cryptic is--
I think it's the best type
of word puzzle out there.
AUDIENCE: Do you
make them yourself?
DAVID KWONG: I've
never made one.
I've never made one.
I struggle through them.
It's a type of word puzzle
that, half of the phrase
is the answer, and the other
half of it is a wordplay clue--
wordplay for that, a
synonym of the answer.
And you don't know
which side is which,
and it's a lot of fun, yeah.
But yeah, "The Times"
has a great one--
AUDIENCE: Awesome, thanks.
DAVID KWONG: --once
a month, yeah.
AUDIENCE: I had a question
about your construction
and how you got your word list.
Because I've been constructing,
and I thought a word list.
And I find that there's
a lot of junk in it.
It takes a lot of time to sift
through how much acceptable bad
stuff you take.
DAVID KWONG: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I don't know
what your [INAUDIBLE]..
DAVID KWONG: I'm so glad
you asked that, because I
said I would come back to it.
When it comes to making
a puzzle with a program,
and you hit Fill,
it's going to populate
it drawing from a word list.
And it's just full of junk.
So you have to sift through it,
and delete stuff, and change
the values to make more
interesting words and longer
phrases, give them higher value.
I'm always adding
things to the word list.
I walk around, I have
this, like, radar
for 15-letter answers.
So you know, "Crazy
Rich Asians"--
15-- like, I'm going to
put that in a puzzle.
Don't you dare put that
in puzzle before I do.
So yeah, I'm always filling
it and taking it out.
And then there are some
crossword puzzle constructors--
there's a small, little
consortium of people--
we can talk about
this if you email me--
where it's a shared list.
And people are updating it.
And then everyone's
downloading a fresh list.
And I'm sure someone here could
come up with a really great way
to do that.
But yeah, you have to--
I don't know why the
default lists that you
buy are just full of garbage.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, they
have so many words
that no one would
ever deem acceptable.
And they're scored in such
a way that it's surprising
why it's scored so high.
So like, I would--
and I was happy to buy
it, because there's
a lot of really good stuff.
But I just hope that
there's something better.
DAVID KWONG: It
gets you started.
And the mark of a great
puzzle, the fill--
the fill, is that it's
all good, you know?
And if you get some
bad stuff in there,
you have to peel back the whole
grid sometimes and start over,
you know?
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
DAVID KWONG: Yeah.
TOM SMITH: OK, We're
getting short on time.
I know we can do
at least one more.
Let's see if we can get two.
AUDIENCE: So I
remember crosswords
before Wikipedia existed
or Google was a thing.
And you know, you had
to think, or ask around,
ask your friends,
go to the library.
Now we have Google
at our fingertips.
How has it changed crosswords?
Have they become harder?
DAVID KWONG: To solve
or to construct?
AUDIENCE: Both.
DAVID KWONG: Yeah, well,
I'll say that, once again,
borrowing from our
great leader Will Shortz
that it is OK to look things up.
It's OK to look up answers.
It's not cheating, so to speak.
You do whatever you have to
do to get through the puzzle,
and appreciate the
construction of the puzzle
and the trick of the puzzle.
But yes, so you used
to have to-- there
was a crossword
dictionary, right?
And you would look
up a key word.
And there would be
all these things that
might be associated with it.
And those all exist
online now as well.
And I think searching has made
constructing a lot easier too.
And there are some
fantastic sites out there
where, if you're
looking for a word that
has a Q in the third
position, you'd
put in question mark, question
mark, Q, and then asterisk,
perhaps, to just say any length.
And there's lots of
engines for that.
AUDIENCE: Are there things that
you would put in today that you
wouldn't, perhaps, 20 years
ago, because you would think,
no one would possibly be
able to find this out?
DAVID KWONG: New words?
AUDIENCE: New clues,
new ways of things
that would be too difficult
before this all existed--
have they become harder?
DAVID KWONG: Harder to--
I don't follow, I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: Harder because--
TOM SMITH: Are you
giving harder clues
because of the availability
of [INAUDIBLE]??
AUDIENCE: Yes.
DAVID KWONG: Oh,
well that would be
assuming that people are looking
things up for the answers.
So no, I think that it
hasn't changed the approach.
It still needs to be common
knowledge or trivia, yeah.
But constructing has
become a lot more fun.
Because you can run--
some of the best
constructors now
are running programs
to find words that
fit these patterns and things.
And you wouldn't be able to
do that 20 years ago, yeah.
Thanks.
TOM SMITH: OK, with
that, we're going
to have to wrap things up.
DAVID KWONG: There's one
more, one more person.
TOM SMITH: OK.
DAVID KWONG:
Literally, that's it.
AUDIENCE: Thanks very much.
As someone who looks for
puzzles, maybe, and crosswords,
your show, escape rooms, are
there events, recommendations,
other places that
you continue to look
for new puzzles in your life?
DAVID KWONG: I haven't done
any escape rooms in New York
yet, because I just moved here.
So I'd welcome your suggestions.
There are great puzzle hunts
that people put out once
a year, twice a year.
Every Labor Day, I
shut down my life,
and go over to my friend's
house for a long weekend,
and do Mark Halpin's
puzzle hunt.
Happy to send me
that information.
There are these beautifully
artfully designed puzzles
within puzzles within puzzles.
The big thing is
MIT's mystery hunt,
which is over the Martin
Luther King weekend.
And there are a
bunch of those also,
other festivals that pop up.
But yeah, I think--
I'm happy to give you a list of
some of the best ones of those.
AUDIENCE: Cool, appreciate it.
Thank you.
DAVID KWONG: OK, cool.
TOM SMITH: And let's give
David a big round of applause.
Thank you for having me.
[APPLAUSE]